hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build this is part two of our
spaceship corridor last week we built
the structure and this week we're gonna
be focusing on building the well really
dressing up the interior and we're gonna
be doing it using really cheap items in
fact some of the stuff is gonna be stuff
that you would normally have thrown away
it's gonna be a lot of plastic
containers and bottles and egg cartons
some really obvious items like a
Gatorade bottle or this cheap plastic
food container that once contained
strawberries or a plastic egg carton
this is almost kind of a staple and all
sci-fi movies I feel like everywhere
there's always an egg carton placed
somewhere it's not multiple places fun
once we paint them and add things to
them they become other things they give
a nice texture to the piece and really
that's what it's kind of about with the
sci-fi element is creating a texture
that you can light very interestingly
and stuff like that it gives the hallway
a little bit more dimension and stuff
like this you can find the hardware
store now this is used for insulation
you can find it in your hardware store
in the installation department and they
only cost about a buck 80 apiece and
they come in smaller panels too and
there's super lightweight it's basically
just a vacuum form plastic it's really
thin and they're really cheap and they
have a great sci-fi look and things like
styrofoam you know if you know you're
gonna be doing a project like this throw
the word out there to all your friends
and family if they're if they have any
styrofoam or anything like that to put
it aside for you or you could even go to
some electronic stores and stuff like
that a lot of times and their back room
they're just gonna be throwing the stuff
away you can talk to one of the managers
or something and say that you're you
know this tone what you're doing or you
want to get the stuff off their hands
I'm sure they'd be more than happy to
just give you a ton of their leftover
styrofoam it's just going to wind up on
their dumpster
anyway or you could just go dumpster
diving behind you know best buy and and
pick out what you like so so the reason
for this build we are going to be using
it for probably one or two nostalgia
critics coming up in your future but
it's also going to be a main piece for a
sci-fi short that I'm working on
currently and so I want to be able to
design it in a way that we can use it
for multiple times and reuse it without
it looking the same in fact we're gonna
have a bunch of builds coming up in the
near future all revolving around this
kind of sci-fi theme and all of them are
gonna have something to do with this
sci-fi project that I'm working on and I
will divulge more about that in the
future as we get closer to it but some
of the projects will involve rod
puppetry and building a robot or
building a robot soup or building a
spacesuit sci-fi weapons scratch
building sci-fi models and ships that
you can shoot on green-screen
so a variety of different things as be a
closer and as I said I'll divulge more
about that project as we get closer but
you will also see I'm sure in some
nostalgia critic episodes coming up soon
so keep that in mind all right so enough
of that that's to start building alright
because this is a project that I've been
planning for a long time I've been
accumulating and saving things for a few
months now so I have a huge pile of
styrofoam pieces that we are going to be
able to use so not all of that is going
to go into this particular build but a
lot of it is going to be used in general
for this overall project also all of
these plastic containers I've got
several bins full of these plastic food
containers I've been saving them all
over the past few months I also have a
ton of plastic and PVC pieces that I
save from other builds or things that
are leftover or scrap or sometimes we
just break down a build and the stuff
that's left over and I have a bunch of
items that I just found at Goodwill or a
dollar store that I just thought would
look interesting different interesting
shapes things like
in a dollar store this is for your
silverware in your drawer but a couple
of these together give an interesting
shape same thing with these dollars to
our food trays flipped around you add
different elements to this and make it
part of something else it kind of blends
in it looks come like it could be a
control pad or something like that
all of these things make this great
things to work with as you're building
especially if you're building somewhat
organically and you're kind of thinking
like well I need that a piece to fit
here or a piece to fit there it's kind
of fun to play with all these different
elements and see what kind of works best
for you so one of the first things we're
gonna do is paint the walls of the
interior of our corridor I'm probably
just gonna go with like a flat gray or
something and then you can either go
lighter or darker from that you want to
have elements that are white or you want
to go darker with darker objects and I
think the gray will be a nice kind of
backdrop to it and it'll give it some
dimension then either way also I want to
point out a way that's kind of going to
be easy to quickly change up how you
dress your set is magnets so I took a
piece of steel flat bar and screwed it
right to my wall then I just took a
piece of styrofoam and glued some little
magnets to the corners so you could just
throw it up there rearrange it if you
wanted
pretty easy it works really well with
super light objects like the styrofoam
or these plastic pieces that I was
talking about I actually just put a
little piece of self-adhesive magnetic
strip on the back and then that to just
throw it up on the magnet now you can
use the bigger sheets or use them
however you want and you can place the
flat bar all the way across or in
different sections depending on how you
want to dress it up but this is going to
make it much easier to dress and redress
your corridor if you're going to be
shooting multiple scenes and it has to
look like multiple corridors just pop
that off throw the next pieces on
whatever I will say though that the
steel flat bar is rather expensive it's
about seven or eight dollars a piece
depending on the piece I think this is a
four-foot piece that was about eight
bucks so it is kind of is kind of pricey
you could just get a roll of steel strap
but you probably just need to use a
stronger magnet for that but it would be
much cheaper I have a few of these I'm
going to use and then I'm probably also
going to be incorporating the steel
strap and then some other ways we're
just going to be mounting directly on to
the board but for now we're gonna paint
it all and then we'll start kind of
dressing it up and seeing what different
stuff you could do
all right so I just used a great primer
and two coats kind of did the trick I
ate some scrap cardboard that I laid out
and just start sifting through all the
pieces and arranging them in a manner
that looks right to you however you kind
of just start arranging the pieces in a
way that looks good to you but I was
like just going with similar patterns
so once I figured out kind of where I
wanted all my elements to be I traced
along the corners of all of them with
Sharpie markers so I would the placement
of the different objects was and then I
used my hot glue gun and went over and
glued them all in place
you can see what a difference the paint
job men
now these plastic panels they're already
black but I wanted to dull him down a
bit so I went over them with krylon flat
black and then I went over that with a
nickel finish just kind of a light
dusting that kind of highlights some of
the different elements and then kind of
give the splash of color I use red oxide
to kind of give it a little bit of a
busted look so when using a Styrofoam
you can't use spray paint because
aerosol and the can actually eats the
foam so I just use the black latex paint
give it a base coat you may have to use
two or three coats depending on the look
you're going with or depending on how
dense and absorbent that styrofoam is
before that dries using dry brushing
with gray or light blue
kind of highlight all of those edges and
raise
now I have tons of scrap wire so I took
different colored wires and blue black
white yellow and nested it together and
taped it together so that I'm gonna use
that to run in between some of the
different elements some of the different
boxes and things and so they can be
hanging and stuff like there's no
ceiling but this will give it an added
texture and give it more of a life to it
this is another way to add some color
and they kind of tied things together
Lieber
so you can start to see some of it
coming together a little bit
alright guys well that's all the time I
have for this week so I guess this is
actually gonna be a three parter there's
still a lot of pieces I'm in the process
of painting and some pieces are drying
and stuff and there's still a lot of
clogging to do basically a lot of fine
details and stuff like that this is just
one possible kind of look or general
look I'm still going to run lots of
wiring and tubing and stuff to kind of
bring it all out we still have to finish
up the top part
yeah sorry that we didn't get to finish
it up this week but next week we'll have
it all finished will be completed
corridor and we'll go into some ways on
how to light it and shoot it so yeah
come on back for part 3 next week once
again thanks so much for watching guys
and don't forget to look me up on
Facebook at James Jim J res and I'll
probably be posting a lot more updates
about this particular sci-fi project
that I'm working out on my facebook
alright so thanks so much for watching
you guys Rach I'll see you next time
you